hello
my name is pamela apkaryan russell and i
am the halloween queen which is my
registered trademark
and this is castle halloween museum
welcome to castle halloween museum ooh
lightning
this fireplace in mantle came from a
miniature golf course in windsor locks
connecticut
we have approximately 35 000 items here
at the museum for 48 years of collecting
whether it's folk art pottery
paintings
spiritualism the salem witch trials
what's a witch without her hat
this is the costume room
there are over a thousand costumes in
this room they were not flame proof and
don't forget these people were using
live candles at this time over here we
cover over 100 years of games but of
course you have the ouija board if
you're a good person you bring good
things out if you're a bad person you're
going to bring bad things out it's you
that brings things to you
memento mori was for remembering the
dead they're interesting because they're
made of human hair it was like having
that person there with you
these are the earth spirits i would love
to have one of these guys come alive in
my yard and just come in here
and and just be part of my life it was
junk as far as people were concerned
that's how i got my monika the halloween
queen we were set up at a very posh
antique show and this man took great
umbrage to my big halloween display
really very snobbish i don't want all
this halloween queen junk i remember
looking at him and saying if you don't
like it leave
now especially after my books came out
and people started seeing the value and
the
sophistication of the artwork and the
beauty of the artwork
then all of a sudden it started coming
out of the woodwork
halloween has nothing to do with blood
and gore
it was a way of giving it represents the
harvest and the fact that you're going
to make it through the winter the life
force being kept unbroken
[Music]
real life can be very very harsh and
ugly
halloween is a healing process
it's like you have a big cauldron of
water and you start putting in all these
wonderful spices
whether it's the voodoo flags the day of
the dead the easter witches from sweden
the troll from norway
it gathers things together it is
intolerant of intolerance this is what
makes our lives richer
hubba hubba dingle dangle
i can see from every angle
who said that it was in a magazine or a
book from a hundred thousand years ago